Thank you for tuning in to Maple Leaf's Worldwide Weather report.
We'll be checking on the weather all over the world with Tim Tiger.
First, Canada.
How's the weather?
It's snowy!
It's snowy in Canada!
Thank you, Tim.
Next, Mexico!
Tim, how's the weather?
It's sunny.
It's sunny in Mexico!
Thank you, Tim.
Next, England.
Tim, how's the weather?
It's foggy.
It's foggy in England.
Thank you, Tim.
Next, France.
Tim, how's the weather?
It's rainy.
It's rainy in France.
Thank you, Tim.
Next, Russia.
Tim, how's the weather?
It's cold.
It's cold in Russia.
Thank you, Tim.
Next, Australia.
Tim, how's the weather?
Hold on!
I'm coming!
It's hot!
It's hot in Australia.
Are you okay, Tim?
I'm good, Marty.
What's next?
Next is Japan.
Japan?
Alright!
Next is Japan.
Tim, how's the weather in Japan?
Tim?
I'm coming!
I'm on my way.
I'm almost there.
It's cloudy.
It's cloudy in Japan.
Thank you, Tim.
Next is Mars.
Mars?
Yes, Mars.
No, Marty, I quit!
Well, thank you for tuning in to Maple Leaf's Worldwide Weather.
See you next time.